Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie Dave Filoni and Jon Favreau
are working on Ahsoka season 2.
They ended season one with a bunch
of cliffhangers and questions.
there were some huge storylines
that they left completely wide open,
like the mortis gods.
There's a bunch of stuff
they've already confirmed.
And we have a pretty good idea
for what's happening
next in this part of the timeline.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I'll be doing more videos
for The Mandalorian.
Season four in the Skeleton Crew
series is actually like the next series
in the timeline
that will crossover with everything,
but that won't premiere
until round Spring 2024.
but just starting with the biggest stuff.
What's happening with the more discards
in live action.
Really cool to see Dave Filoni do this.
The funny thing is,
originally it was George
Lucas's idea to create the more disguise
for the Clone Wars.
So a lot of people, if you're wondering
what was the deal with them
during the Clone Wars, George Lucas
wanted to introduce them into the canon
the story that George laid out for us
was something that I think that
that we'd all
as Star Wars fans, as lovers of mythology,
wanted to delve into
for a very long time,
which was a much more intensive look at
the force and
force wielders and how that used
in this whole prophecy of the Chosen one.
And what does that mean for
the one who I was actually out of the room
for the first,
I think 15 minutes, 20 minutes of George's
pitch of these force wielders.
And I remember coming back in the room
and the writers
were all just kind of wrapped up,
like looking at George.
And they saw me come in the room
and they looked at me and they're like,
You've got to hear this.
And George sat me down
and he started explaining to the gods,
and we are before.
They're much more powerful
than any grenades.
And this one turns into a gargoyle.
And this one.
GRIFFIN And he's saying all this stuff.
You're
like, Wow, this is pretty intense.
that whole storyline came from him.
And Dave Filoni
just kind of adapted it to the page.
but what is Baylan Skoll
trying to do with them?
And what is Dave Filoni going to do
with the character of Baylan Skoll
since Rey Stephenson passed away
before the series premiered?
May he rest in peace?
no joke.
He was one of the most interesting things
about this season.
I was a little disappointed.
There was so little of the character.
It kind of feels like Dave Filoni wrote
a bunch more stuff for him, and Shehata
on the page then went up cutting
a lot of their scenes for budget reasons.
But that mortis gods teaser at the end
was enough to answer
most of the big questions.
Like the what of it all
during that final scene we see him
standing on the statue of the father
on the fist, staring out at a beacon
on a mountain in the distance.
Is it?
The father is pointing to the mountain.
Next to it is a statue of the sun.
And then next to
them is a crumbling statue
that are this broken
because they're ancient statues.
like the statues were meant
to have been built by the witch.
Which kingdom of the death
mere thousands of years ago
during the height of their civilization.
that's why you see the statues
all around the planet's surface.
But the other statues
are meant to look like the same statue
above the Knight's sister's coven on Darth
the Mirror during the Clone Wars
that mother tells and ruled over
That figure that they depict
I think is meant to be an ancient knight's
sister,
probably one of the ancient great members
of that order in the way
the Sith have statues to Darth
Roman, the other ancient
Sith from the Old Republic era. but.
The whole idea here
is that the ancient night
sisters of this ancient witch kingdom
built statues to the mortis gods, meaning
they also probably worshiped them
and used their power.
And this goes back to the history of the
universe that the father told to and again
during the Mortis episodes
when he visited them in The Clone Wars.
there's like this whole untold history
of the universe that and again, gets like
a big info dump on what happened many,
many hundreds of thousands of years ago.
the father told him that in ancient times
the mortis gods walked
amongst humans in the mortal realm
like the normal universe
in their level of power and influence.
And the force was so great
that it caused all kinds of calamities
and collateral damage,
even though they didn't
necessarily intend to do that
just the fact
that they were sitting around
in the moral round caused so much chaos
and schism between the dark side,
the light side, wars everywhere,
so much death and destruction,
the is the because the son was the conduit
of the dark side, the force.
He would cause this huge rise in the power
of the dark side of the force,
the level of the dark side in the universe
causing way more wars, death, destruction.
generally the dark side
will hold sway over the entire universe
like dark timeline kind of stuff.
Then on a dime,
it would shift to the light side
when the daughter would do the same thing
and she would hold
sway over the universe in the father
would be constantly trying to create
balance between the dark and the light
to stop the entire universe
from being destroyed.
The father said that eventually
what happened
is that he
removed the three of them to the pocket
dimension called the Mortis realm.
But even though they weren't
physically touching the mortal plane,
the normal universe,
the three of them still had
a lot of influence
over the state of the galaxy.
Dark light in the balance between them.
So that's how powerful they were.
Like they were in an alternate dimension,
but they still have this extreme influence
over the galaxy.
that's why the sun tried to trick an Akin
the others, into releasing him
from the Mordor strong so they could go
back to the main universe.
Is that had happened.
It would have been lights out
for the universe
like the power
and influence of the dark side
would become so great to someone
like Emperor Palpatine would gain
God tier power
compared to his normal level of power.
it would basically boost all the natural
power levels of all dark side
force users, no matter what.
during the series, though,
they hint the fall of the ancient witch
kingdom of the death mirrored
the ancient Knights sisters.
Huge empire was because of something
connected to the mortals gods,
probably the sun.
most of the power that they wield
seems like it has a twinge of darkness.
Like we give you a gift of shadows
to Morgan Elsbeth,
clearly very dark side terminology here
the way the Knights sisters
tap into the force,
though, is a little bit different.
So it's not quite
as binary is light side and dark side.
that was what Baylan Skoll
was talking about
when he said that we are no Jedi, but
they're also not Sith either, going back
to the whole concept of the mortis, Gods
like the sun tells the others, I am not.
I'm not merely says.
I'm much more than that.
the bend.
Do kind of gets into that too,
like the way he wields the force
in a much more complete way,
dark side and light side together.
What I think Dave Filoni is doing here
is saying that the father story
about the reason they left
the mortal realm
was because of the trouble they cause in
it has something to do
with the fall of the witch
kingdom of the Dathomir
like they started to be influenced
by the sun.
The Rays grew in power
like they turned into an empire,
but ultimately
it caused their destruction.
Then the father took the three of them
to the mortis realm.
So you have to remember
this is happening hundreds of thousands,
if you like, a long time ago.
In the past, Morgan Elspeth said that
it was before time itself was recorded,
meaning that it predated
the beginning of the original Jedi order.
in that goes back about 35,000 years.
we're going deep into like stuff
that predates Knights of the Old Republic.
I also think these three main Knights
sister, great mothers,
went into hibernation until Thrawn
and Morgan Elspeth woke them up
During the series.
They say that Thrawn and the others
woke them up, quote unquote.
I think that's meant to be a literal thing
Like these three knights
sisters, Claudia Black being the main one,
even though they kind of exist
in a trinity with equal power.
Her name is Cloak, though
they're each name
for the three Greek fates
who would perceive destiny.
I think that these three were actually
from that ancient witch kingdom in
survived.
It just spent thousands of years
in hibernation until Thrawn arrived
and woke them up in that explains
how they survived until present day.
Another basically trying to bring back
the witch Kingdom of the Death mirror
in present day with Thrawn help.
And that's
why they're agreeing to work with him.
But this explains how those three survive
to present day.
Many, many thousands of years.
They were basically just in deep storage.
those Raiders on the planet that we met
I think were just meant to be the long,
long descendants of the Knights Sisters
and the Knight Brothers from that era.
but this kind of explains why they kept
saying there was this puzzle of death
and decay over the pretty planet
like something terrible happened here.
They're probably talking about what
those ancient mortis gods did originally.
is basically the wasteland left over from
the things that the brother,
the mortis gods did to the witch kingdom
that eventually caused this calamity
that created the downfall.
Their race.
now in present day though, Baylan Skoll
seems like
he's trying to find a place on the planet
like that mountain in the distance
with the beacon
that will give him access
to the mortis realm.
He could also be looking to enter
the world between worlds too,
because the mortals gods had a mural near
the entrance of mortis during rebels.
so their appearance on the series
could also herald another entrance
to the world between worlds.
Either way, it looks like Balan skull
is playing to end the cycle of all, warned
the universe.
That's what he said he wants to do.
Like we don't want any more order 66.
So he wants to end all war everywhere
in the universe. in.
In order to do that,
he would need the power
on the level of the more smallest gods
so he could be seeking to make himself
a new mortis. God, no.
Unless De Vallone changes
the mortis Gods backstory in present day,
the original mortis gods were supposed
to have died during the Clone Wars.
The exception to
this is the Meri owl in Ahsoka herself.
so Meri contains
some of the life force of the daughter.
We saw her during the like.
Ahsoka sees the owl, but the owl shows up
every time that Ahsoka shows up.
like she helped Ezra in Ahsoka
when they were in the War between Worlds
and then on The Mandalorian
when the Sokka debut during season two,
we also saw the Maori owl.
There are two part of the reason why
there's such a strong connection between
Mirai and Ahsoka is because they both
contain life force of the daughter.
Literally, Ahsoka
has the life force of the daughter back
during the Mortis episodes.
Ahsoka was about to die in.
The daughter
essentially gave her remaining life force
to bring her back to life, to heal her.
so when present day
Mirai and Ahsoka are like the last living
remnants
of the daughter, avatars of the daughter.
no. I don't know if Dave Filoni is going
to turn that into something bigger.
Like some of you asked me
if this means Ahsoka will become
the daughter's replacement.
Is a mortis.
God herself in the way that Aniket is kind
of replacing the mortis Gods,
The father basically told.
And again, this was his destiny
to bring balance to the force.
But on a more cosmic scale in remember,
this is George Lucas's idea
to create that storyline.
So he wanted an akin to take over
balance of the force in a more cosmic way.
That's the funny thing
with theories like that,
when people are like,
No, that sounds crazy.
Why would any can ever become a God?
Well, it was George
Lucas's idea to have this God
tell him that he was going to replace him
eventually.
when you hear about
some of the deleted scenes
from the prequels in the original trilogy,
George
Lucas did have a lot of really crazy ideas
that just never wound up
on the actual final cuts.
But that's why in present day,
you're seeing all this weird stuff
like this force lure.
The more or less gods start to take shape
in live action Because George Lucas had
all these really big ideas that he wanted
to start in the animated episodes.
this means that a Baylan Skoll
wants to use the power of the Mortis gods
and eventually winds up becoming one of
the more says are similar to one of them.
He could become like
the new version of The Sun,
even if that's not entirely
what he's planning.
He's playing just trying to use the power
of the mortis gods.
In an early theory, in a wind up
driving him mad in an account in a sock.
We'll have to do something
to stop him from destroying the universe
unintentionally.
Kind of the same way
the brother eventually would have done
that had Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Ahsoka in anarchy,
not stop him from leaving mortis.
but I think we're all on the same page,
though, that Dave
Filoni will have to recast Ray
Stephenson's Baylan Skoll character.
He's just way too big for them
to not continue that story arc.
they might just fast track Ahsoka
Season two and do that
after The Mandalorian Season four
and just continue
all these plot threads during that.
Instead of waiting for the Thrawn movie.
before the season premiered, my theory was
they would just do a full trilogy
of Thrawn movies
that the first one works out.
Like if it does well financially
and they just cover the rest
of all those storylines over the next
7 to 8 hours of that movie trilogy.
I think their idea now is that
they'll just do seasons of Ahsoka
the Mandalorian
Skeleton Crew between the three movies
any of their spinoffs they want to do end
that'll give them the time
to stretch these movies out
so they don't have to rush them out
too quickly.
You also have to remember the way
they paced things out like it was
a glacial pace during Ahsoka season one.
It'll be like that on the
Mandalorian season for the other series.
like it's going to be a while before
we get answers to a lot of these questions
that also means that there's a crossover
between Ahsoka Season
one and The Mandalorian Season four.
It'll probably be through Ezra Bridgers
character in The New Republic.
Characters like Carson Tiba.
He was kind of the Mandalorian Season
three
crossover character
during the Circle Season one,
like standing up,
Hey everybody, remember all the stuff
we just did in The Mandalorian Season
three?
basically reminding
everybody about what was going on
with the Mandalorians in present day,
they'll probably have
a similar type of moment
during the Mandalorian season four,
maybe like another Zeb cameo scene
because he's a Rebels character
and he's on Carson Tevez's team
and what they might do to get
the mandalorians involved
in the war against
Thrawn is basically do what they did
during the Mandalorian season three.
So Carson Deva, when did the mandalorians
in told them about everything?
Because The New Republic didn't
want to believe that there was a threat.
So during The Mandalorian Season four,
you have to imagine Carson, Tiba
and Ezra Bridge are going to Mando
grow goo the Mandalorians and say,
Hey, look, there's this giant fleet.
Thrawn is back.
He brought a bunch of nice sisters
with them.
There's a zombie army
that they're going to resurrect,
And that explains how the mandalorians
wind up in the Thrawn movie.
The next big teaser was Ahsoka
taking the sort of tools
in that the Knights sisters gave to Morgan
Elsbeth.
Remember, that's the exact same sword
that mother tells to use
during the Clone Wars
and during the episode they literally use
their force abilities to pull it
across galaxies, across space
and time to give it to Morgan Elsbeth.
Too bad they can't pull each other
across galaxies.
That would come in really handy.
What will probably happen is
the sword will slowly begin to corrupt
Ahsoka and influence her the same way
the Sith Hall across an influence.
Ezra Bridger during the rebels episode,
he got darker and darker until Kanan
gave it to the bender.
You the probably give a soldier
a similar type of arc
that Ezra had with that hologram.
Meanwhile, Ezra, back in the main
galaxy, will spend most of his time
with Hera,
the New Republic, trying to convince them
the threat of Thrawn, who is now
back on Dathomir with the Knights Sisters
in Thrawn in the Knights.
Sisters will be preparing to resurrect
his dead bodies in the caskets.
Marshal the forces of the Shadow Council,
the remnant empire that'll take some time
to gather all those forces.
But Dathomir will be their staging point.
that'll probably continue
to go on in the background
during the Mandalorian season
four and Grogan
and Mando will just hear about it
through Carson Tiba in Ezra, like I said,
early idea is that they just warn him
about Thrawn in the Knights Sisters.
that little teaser with Anakin Skywalker's
fourth ghost at the end
is probably going to pick up
at the beginning of season two,
and he will help Ahsoka
figure out a way to get back
and what to do next just in general.
Tying back into this whole more
disguised Baylan Skoll plot.
as for Luke Skywalker
and his Jedi Academy, everybody wondering
when they're going to involve
Luke in the story.
I think if they fast track Ahsoka
season two,
then they'll just save his next cameo
for that Thrawn movie,
giving them enough time to introduce
these other characters and flesh
out these other storylines and get better
with their deepfake technology
so that when they do Luke again,
it looks way, way better
But the whole idea was Sabine
and now Grogu. Who is that?
They're like, the next Mandalorian
Jedi is after Tara Vizsla,
the person who created the Darksaber.
A lot of you also asking
if Callixtus in Marin
will show up during the storyline
because they're alive in this part of
the timeline, they're saving live action.
Carl KASELL
So after the third game in his trilogy,
which he actually just confirmed himself
that they're working on right now,
the problem with that is it
usually takes them about four years
to get those games out.
So we're not really expecting
live action caucuses until after 2026.
they could also swerve on that idea
and just give them their own live action
series in it totally be fine.
There's enough material
with all those characters
to do their own series
that could run for seven seasons.
but I'm sure everybody has a thousand
more questions
about all the characters
and what's happening next in the timeline.
So post them all in the comments below.
right now,
the Skeleton Crew series
is supposed to pick up
the next part of the story,
but that's like a totally new group
of characters
in a totally new part of the galaxy.
It's supposed to take place
in the unknown,
but they also might wind up in that
new parity, a galaxy, the other galaxy,
the other big reminder
is that my Loki Season 2 Episode 1
video will post next.
Be sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss that in.
Congratulations to Gary from Brooklyn.
You're the giveaway winner
from my last big Star Wars video. Please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for my full episode 8 video
and click here to learn how Anakin
Skywalker is becoming a mortis
God, Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
and this is the way!